es passierte während der massenproteste
gegen das umstrittene auslieferungs
gesetz in hongkong
obwohl am sonntag nach angaben der
veranstalter zwei millionen menschen
gegen die pläne der regierung auf die
strasse gingen blieben die
demonstrationen friedlich und nicht nur
das die menschen zeigten sich überaus
diszipliniert als ein krankenwagen zu
demonstranten fahren musste die wegen
der hitze zusammengebrochen waren
bildeten die menschen eine rettungsgasse
dort wo der wagen die demonstranten
passiert hatte schloss sich die kasse
wieder und das ohne dass irgendwelche
ordnungskräfte zu sehen waren es sah
fast noch so etwas wie ein herr
magischen hand aus die für ordnung
sorgte in den sozialen netzwerken wurden
diese aufnahmen ausgiebig geteilt und
voller bewunderung kommentiert
[Applaus]